mine de rien ces champignons sont des
trésors
ils contiennent de la chitine avec son
dérivé le kit osant ils ont de
nombreuses propriétés utile dans
plusieurs secteurs d'activité ces deux
scientifiques de la société amie roy ont
mis au point un procédé écologique pour
fabriquer du kit osant c'est la
technologie de fabrication qui est
différente cette fois-ci on n'utilise
pas les traitements chimiques
on utilise les êtres vivants comme les
bactéries et les champignons qui mange
un peu les autres réparties conte qui
nous intéresse pas et la partie qui est
inique qui est qui nous intéresse c'est
le plus dur à digérer pour les bactéries
et ils ne mangent pas donc on le
récupère à la fin du procédé pour
l'instant à me roy est encore en phase
de prototypage les premiers débouchés
sont pour l'agriculture biologique
le kit aux ans est connu pour ses
capacités à protéger les semences et
aussi à booster leur croissance les
scientifiques vont encore plus loin en
multipliant les essais voilà vous qui
est vraiment chaque espèce à différents
besoins
donc on pour nous c'est important on va
respecter cette différence entre les
espèces de plantes par exemple si vous
misez sur les pauvres en là un progrès
social et potins haut nous avons un
produit qui est ce que c'est loge
parce que c'est pas la même chose en
elle n'est pas la même dosage et voilà
l'un des résultats de l'application du
kit osant à gauche son traitement à
droite avec qui tu oses en ami roy s'est
associé avec un agriculteur pour la
distribution de ces kits osant
scientifique et paysans les voilà tous
les deux sur le terrain l'exploitant a
déjà enrobé ces semences de blé de
printemps avec ce nouveau produit
c'était il ya un mois aujourd'hui il
peut déjà en observer les effets un beau
développement en chine air c'est vrai ça
ça a bien marché
et puis et puis nerveux à côté n'est
toujours pas développé on va pas d'air
mais aussi en la matière vont à l'herbe
à volants m sinon c'est vraiment la
différence
je trouve que mon blé a poussé
uniformément et appris beaucoup d'avant
par rapport à toutes les autres herbes
et du coup va se réaliser pleinement et
qui disent réaliser pleinement donc je
devrais faire une très bonne récolte une
quarantaine d'exploitations bio en
bourgogne franche comté et champagne
ardenne expérimente les kits osant d'un
miroir
alors on va les 250
c'est vraiment un mot la vie un marché
très important une application très
important et en même temps très
écologique et qui protège les
agriculteurs oui surtout simplement
médecin de l'as manche
et bien aujourd'hui la plupart des
autres produits on peut pas mettre le
nez dans l'espace que c'est dangereux
ahmed sheikh de 16 ans a choisi de
s'installer à arc les gray au coeur de
la haute saône le département de
bourgogne franche comté qui est le plus
de surfaces agricoles en bio
ça